everyone welcome to today's your daily
equation and when I asked a little while
ago for your favorite equations
equations that people really wanted me
to say a few words about the
overwhelming winner of that little
informal survey were the equations of
quantum mechanics Schrodinger's equation
dubrow equation things of that sort so
indeed I'm going to focus on one of
those equations today in fact it is the
dubrow formula for the wavelength of a
particle and I'm going to jump in to the
subject and if some of a historical
manner then I'll backtrack and fill in a
little bit of the history I'm going to
begin with a modern-day version of an
experiment it's called the double slit
experiment and I'll describe the
original version of that experiment as
it was carried out back in the 1920s but
let's first begin with this very
pedagogical experiment in fact the
famous physicist Richard Feynman once
famously said that in the double slit
experiment you kind of see all of
quantum mechanics right there and that's
kind of rare for one single experiment
to kind of embody an entire deep and
profound subject but that's what this
experiment is able to do okay so with
that build up I think many of you are
familiar with it what is the double slit
experiment well let me just bring up a
version of it here imagine you begin
with some kind of gun firing pellets or
bb's at a barrier that has two slits the
double slits what do you think the data
will look like in terms of the pellets
that make it through well as you see on
the screen it's just what you would
think right you've got some of the
pellets that land in a band on the Left
aligned with that opening that slit and
you got other pellets that land in a
band on the right aligned with that
opening in the barrier that slit so this
is the double slit experiment carried
out with macroscopic objects pellets B
B's bullets whatever I'm now going to
make one little
and that changes I'm simply going to
dial down the size of the projectiles
I'm gonna take those metallic pellets as
bb's dial them down so that they are the
size of little particles little
electrons now naively you would think
that simply changing the size of the
projectiles should not in any way have
some kind of profound impact on the
results so you would think let me bring
it up here that this is what would
happen again those electrons that make
it through the left opening land in a
band on the left those that make through
the right should land in a band on the
right straightforward and intuitive
logical reasoning leads you to that
conclusion however when you actually do
the experiment here is what actually
happens you don't just get two bands
aligned with the two slits in the double
slit experiment instead as you see you
get a whole series of bands in fact you
get a series that goes from dark to
bright to dark to bright dark bright and
so forth and the fact that you don't
just get two bands the fact that you get
a whole series of bands is one of the
greatest revolutionary moments in
physics because this portends a
completely different way of thinking
about matter which itself yields a
completely different way of thinking
about reality so so where do we get that
kind of a deep insight from so we look
at this this data this bright dark
bright dark did we stare at more like
what in the world is going on and then a
bell kind of rings if you've had any
training or any study of the motion of
waves right because you no doubt are
familiar that a few for instance have a
pebble and you throw it into a pond it
sets off a nice series of concentric
waves that spread outward these circular
waves
if you throw a second pebble into that
pond nearby
than those two sets of concentric waves
will crisscross and when they crisscross
something very interesting happens at
those locations where the peak of one
wave crosses the peak of another the
wave is high those locations were the
trough the bottom of one wave crosses
the trough of another very deep but
there are also locations where the peak
of one wave crosses the trough of
another and they cancel each other out
and at that location the water won't be
agitated at all so for those of you who
had a deprived upbringing and never
threw pebbles into a pond let me let me
just show you that I have a little
visual of that one here so imagine you
throw a little pebble on the right and
there you've got the concentric water
waves going around now throw another
pebble in on the left and here you have
the criss-crossing of the water waves
and again there are locations where the
wave comes together from the left and
the right sources and make the water
highly agitated but there are places in
between you can sort of see them here
highlighted them in these dark regions
where the waves are cancelling each
other out so in essence you have a lot
of agitation a little agitation no
agitation a lot of agitation little
agitation no agitation and that is very
similar to the bright dark bright dark
pattern that we saw in the double slit
experiment with electrons let me even
make that connection a little bit more
obvious so here is a version of throwing
a pebble into a pond one single pebble I
have one single opening and as you see
the water is going through that opening
causing these concentric waves and on
that back screen I'm using the
brightness of the screen to indicate the
agitation of the water so it's highly
agitated where it's very bright and as
you head off left and right the waves
kind of die out and it becomes darker on
the screen so that's like throwing one
pebble into a pond not only throw two in
how do I do that I have two openings the
two concentric waves are now Chris
as I described you get regions of high
agitation little agitation and no
agitation that's the surprising thing
where the waves crisscross the top of
one cross at the bottom of another and
now if on the screen I also use
brightness to indicate the agitation of
the water look at what we have highly
agitated bright dark when there's no
agitation bright dark bright dark
look at that back screen it's just like
the data that we had when we fired
particles at the barrier with the two
openings the barrier with the two slits
in it so we seem to be coming upon some
weird unexpected wave-like phenomenon
but in an experiment when we are firing
particles at the barrier with the two
openings now I could imagine at first
sight you say hey you know sounds
surprising but if you think it through
it's actually not that surprising
because we all know that water is itself
composed of particles composed of
molecules 8 2o molecules and so even in
the experiment with water we are
actually throwing particles at the
barrier with the two openings and so
maybe the fact that we get this
interference pattern which is the
technical term for the bright dark
bright dark the interference of the two
waves from the two openings maybe it
isn't surprising that we also get that
when we fire a different species of
particles not h2o molecules but little
electrons and that's a reasonable
assumption or assumptions the wrong word
that's a reasonable suggestion a better
word but let's follow it through and see
whether that could be the answer could
it be that in the experiment with the
electrons it's just that the electrons
are acting like water waves which are
highly choreographed motion of h2o
molecules maybe the electrons are
following a highly choreographed motion
and you're sort of getting a wave from
the law
collection of electrons just like you
can get away from a large collection of
h2o molecules how would you test that
well go back and do the double slit
experiment firing one electron at a time
if you fire one at a time then there's
no opportunity for a large collection to
somehow bang into each other and yield
this pattern from their choreographed
motion so let's do that
so fire one electron at a time and at
first it's just a random sequence of
dots that are forming on that detector
screen but if you wait long enough and
allow the dots to build up over time
holy smokes look what happens you
recreate the interference pattern and in
this case it's not as though away from
one opening is crossing literally away
from the other if you're thinking purely
in the particle language here the
individual particles dot by single dot
are building up that interference
pattern which tells us that even
individual particles have some intrinsic
wave-like quality because they're
yielding wave-like data on that detector
screen being built a single particle by
single particles so your suggestion was
a good one that maybe it was a large
number of electrons like a large number
water molecule somehow banging off each
other but those individual electrons are
not banging off each other
they're hitting that screen individually
one at a time yet we're still getting
the interference pattern now look I
could also imagine you said to me hey
nice animation but does this actually
happen in the real world
I mean a good question is how many of
you have actually ever seen the double
slit experiment really done I mean not
just done in pictures in a textbook or
animation scene it really done and I
have to tell you until I don't know
about eight or ten years ago I'd never
actually seen it done right I'm a
theorist I sort of stay away from
equipment but I had a a show which
basically it's gonna go on the road at
some point I think the next year or two
called
spooky action estates show and in that
state show I brought out the double-slit
experiment did it in real time in front
of the audience and have to tell you the
audience's were often well-versed in the
ideas of quantum mechanics but when the
curtain went up and the actual double
slit experiment was undertaken on stage
they were oohs and ahhs sort of like you
know people were were shocked to
actually see this thing in real life so
let me show you some real data I can't
do these I'd love to set up the double
slit experiment behind me right now I'm
doing a real-time but it can't actually
do that I don't have the equipment here
but let me show you some real data that
was taken I think first actually in the
1980s even though these are old ideas
this version of the experiment was
really only first done in the 1980s a
group at Hitachi
gathered together this data and let me
just show you it so this is these dots
here now not animation these dots are
actual landing locations of actual
electrons and an actual version of the
double slit experiment and look you sort
of have a constellation of random dots
at first I'm going to speed this up
because we'd be sitting here for a long
time and look the real world is never as
clean and pristine as a theoretical
world the animated world that is based
on equations but even though the data is
a little bit noisy and messy compared to
the clean pictures that I showed you
look you can see the interference
pattern here right you can clearly see
that there are brighter regions and
darker regions and brighter regions you
see that band-like interference pattern
even in real-world data of the double
slit experiment so as I mentioned this
was I think first done in the in the
1980s the experiment itself of course
was carried out first in the 1920s in
fact I can show you one of the early
papers of Davisson and Germer who
carried out this experiment Bell Labs
and point out to you I don't know if you
can see it on the screen but you can
google this paper online of course but
if you look at the the first paragraph
after the abstract
it says I'll just read it to the
investigation reported in this paper was
begun as the result of an accident which
occurred in the laboratory in April 1925
an accident right now most physicists
today if there was an accident that
yielded an interesting result that kind
of wouldn't tell you it was an accident
they'd say hey I was sitting in my
office and I had this inspired idea and
I just carried it out here or we
typically don't give you the
behind-the-scenes look any longer so
this is kind of beautiful back in the
1920s that they were willing to tell the
story of what actually happened and the
story is they were firing electrons at a
nickel crystal okay but they turned up
the intensity so high that the evacuated
chamber which is surrounded by glass
exploded okay and when it exploded the
nickel sample got tarnished by the air
that rushed in so they clean up the
nickel sample by heating it to get off
like that tarnished surface unwittingly
by heating up the sample they changed it
they caused the the scattering centers
to blend to melt together into larger
and more separated scattering centers
which as it turns out gives you a
version of the double slit experiment
not completely obvious but there's a
direct link between these two ideas of
scattering electrons off of this nickel
crystal that's been modified in the
manner that they did by heating it and
the double slit that I showed you the
more intuitively obvious version but in
the end they're actually the same and
the data that they acquired let me just
show you to it on the next page here you
can see in the graphs that you sort of
have this up and down this bright dark
bright dark pattern in the data so this
is this paper written in 1927 and what
Davidson and Germer had unwittingly done
is actually confirmed an idea that had
been put forward by somebody else prince
louis de bruyne a very brilliant
physicist who was thinking about
Einsteins ideas and the ideas that were
emerging from conversations of people
like Niels Bohr one of the founding
fathers of quantum
annex and came up with the following
idea which finally is our equation of
the day our daily equations let me just
show you this over here so what was
deployed doing debris said hey there's
something very interesting that happened
in the photoelectric effect with
Einstein what happened there was Ison
said hey you normally think about light
as a wave but now I'm asking you to
think about light as a particle as
photons to explain the data in the
photoelectric effect so we kind of went
from waves to particles debry says hey
maybe the reverse is also true maybe
things that we normally think about as
particles may also be waves and he kind
of reasons in the following way he says
look in the photoelectric effect we
learned that e equals H nu for the
energy of a photon where the light has
frequency nu now this I'm also some
other good equations to record so the
speed of light is equal to the
wavelength of light times its frequency
and there's also another little equation
that's good to bear in mind which is
that energy can be written as momentum
times C when you're talking about light
and look there's an interesting whole
other equation that's worth thinking
about
let me just record it over here which is
e squared minus P squared C squared
equals M naught squared C to the fourth
this is another version of basically
equals MC squared and the reason it's
good to have this is people often say
hey if light is composed of photons and
photons don't have any mass and equals
MC squared if mass is equal to zero then
we should also have energy is equal to
zero but that's actually not true the
rest mass of photons is equal to zero
but that then just leads the equation e
squared equals p squared C squared or e
equals PC as I wrote down over there so
that's another equation maybe
some point I'll spend a little bit of
time on that but the bottom line that
I'm driving at right here is Dubrow says
hey if you look at all these equations
then we can write E as PC equals H nu or
we can write P equals H nu over C but nu
/ see from this equation over here is
just equal to 1 upon lambda 1 divided by
the wavelength so that means P is equal
to H over lambda or lambda is equal to H
over P and that is the equation that is
dubrow's formula now he says look I may
have derived this in the context of
photons but let me imagine let me
conjecture let me hypothesize let me
propose that this is a more general
formula that might work for particles of
matter so a particle of matter like an
electron has a certain momentum right
nonrelativistic Li you may recall from
high school P is equal to M times V that
V is not a new that's the velocity of
the particle so nonrelativistic Li P
equals MV and you could stick that P in
this formula and from that you'd have a
wavelength associated with a particle
and there you have a nice little formula
that says lambda the wavelength of a
wave associated with a particle is given
by this number H Oh remember this is
Planck's constant perhaps I should have
said that it's just a number which is
about 6.6 times 10 to the minus 34
joule-seconds just a number that comes
out of experiment and the beautiful
thing is if you use this formula clearly
have an upcoming appointment that you
just saw on that little reminders I
better finish this up so if you use this
formula in trying to understand the data
that comes out of say the Davidson
Germer experiment then the separation
between the peaks and troughs the dark
and light bands in the interference
pattern
is dependent upon the wavelength of the
waves that are going through the two
slits and indeed this formula allows you
to explain the data that Davisson and
Germer had found unwittingly in that
experiment that emerged from the
accident so you see that things are
really coming together now in the 1920s
you have de bruyne suggesting that not
only can waves look like particles but
particles can look like waves and
actually gives a formula for the
wavelength associated with a particle of
a given momentum and then in this
experiment by Davisson and Germer
they actually find that electrons
through what amounts to a double slit
behave like particles whose wavelength
is indeed given by this number H divided
by the momentum of the particles
confirming the idea that debris had put
forward so this is a giant step forward
in the trajectory toward the quantum
laws of physics there are a few vital
steps still to go that we will cover in
subsequent episodes but this profound
formula that comes from dubrow that the
wave length comes from H over P is a key
step in that progression and will carry
on in subsequent episodes with the
Schrodinger equation and the
probabilistic interpretation of quantum
mechanics all that is coming up but for
today that's all I wanted to say so
until next time take care this is your
daily equation